What we thought, well you could kind of fill in as your hosts's quizmaster because we've got some questions, lots of questions
Now this is a
This is like a Friends trivia. Oh, oh, she's gonna win. Oh I don't know that.
Well really I think you, there's some that you'll know, if they don't know then I'm sure the audience will know
Okay now here are the questions, okay
Okay. All set, Judy no cheating
You'll all compete. Yeah, I know the answers, so i can't
So I'd  like you to put your hand up if you know the answer
Yes sir. And then I'll ask you, is that fair enough?
Yes
Are you ready Judy. Yes, sort of, yes
Question. What is Rachel wearing in her first ever scene? Oh, oh, I can't answer that. Yes you can.
A wedding dress. A wedding dress is the correct answer. Well done, well done.
OMG look how cute that is
Next question, what is the next line
After 'this is about you being a brat, wanting what you can't have'?
Reese. 'Can't have. The only thing I can't have is dairy'. Correct
Because I said it on the show. It's one of the best lines. I said that line on the show.  Yeah yeah
Oh I see
Question. How did Rachel ruin the British trifle?
Ohh...ow
I put... I put beef in it, beef at the bottom
I layered beef into the trifle. You didn't, you didn't, you put shepherd's pie. Oh. right. And shepherd's pie's not made with beef
It's made with lamb sheep lamb
He's firm but fair
Wouldn't expect a landlord to know that sort of stuff. Yes, yes.
What song does Rachel sing to get her daughter to stop crying?
Baby got back.
Baby got back is the correct answer. Yes, that's one for the audience. And for a bonus point
Jennifer, would you like to sing the opening line of the song? Uh, I like big butts and I cannot lie
Very good, extra point
You'd sing that to a child. I know, yes.
I thought you meant the opening line of the theme song. Ohh
Cause I could have told you that. Do you want to sing that? 'So no-one told you that it's gonna be this way'.
On it
Have you got one last one? Yes, and this is for you. For me?! Judy. The question is, when Ross dated Rachel
Why did he feel it was fine to sleep with other women?
I know it, it's
Because he said we were on a break
Correct!
Is that right? Yeah. Well done.